[Music]
ni P have one Gamescom 2014 ladies and
gentlemen 1613 it finally happens second
place finishes finally claim the title
the champions the best team in the world
ninjas in pyjamas when Dignitas
announced the signing of ninjas in
pyjamas old major winning roster it was
impossible to escape the negative
comments sure these players are legends
but they haven't really done anything in
pro play in a long time there are even
some people who think a lot of these
players should have already retired on
paper this roster should fail but what
if what if they don't fail what if they
win what if they qualify for a major and
show the world that age is really just a
number that with the right surroundings
and hard work nothing is impossible and
these Grizzles bets prove that they're
not washed I get it right you see it and
there's probably better alternatives but
here's the thing it's poking up where
the best you got to understand this
roster and why everyone loves them we
need to go back all the way to 2012 in
the release of Counter Strike global
Offensive
[Music]
back then ninjas in pyjamas were the
game's first super team get right
forests and exist came from 1.6 well
Freiburg and four flarin played sourced
but together they built CS goes first
dynasty they played on an entirely
different level than any other teams
putting up an unimaginable 87 Maps in a
row it's been almost seven years no
other team has come close to matching
that record and it's unlikely they ever
will
ni he was so dominating people were
starting to get bored of pro csgo yes it
feels kind of boring to see that we
waiting all the time but all the time
but like at least the tournament along
LAN and I guess the position is saying
the fans actually watching say it's
turning into a boring game they're
insane run and stuffed trophy case
aren't the only reasons why this roster
is so beloved sure they spent a lot of
time winning which earned them a lot of
fans but people kept coming back for the
players personalities
they were deadly on the server and
hilarious off of it actually having the
scam it in real money but nothing even
funny I used to play a lot of sins and I
used to name one of the family's fanatic
yeah so I can go and kill them over and
over again Justin Bieber even won the
greatest prize there is to win in csgo a
major an IP have won Gamescom 2014
ladies and gentlemen 1613 it finally
happens but it's been six years since
that major and these guys haven't won
anything in a long time exist was Ben
ston fanatic Fryeburg was team 'less
after an unimpressive stint with heroic
even get right step down from n IP
starting lineup after underperforming is
this the last time we'll see you at
Alexis [ __ ] no so you're not retiring he
says no the only player who most people
thought was still competitive was
Forrest who continued to produce numbers
for net Ethan in a one-on-one now
against Forrest breezy was caught from
the backside the ball planted forest he
can stop this and delay it surely not
energy are gone for the full deep use
force can see it come down the corner
the clutches around and what people are
excited to have them back because
nostalgia is a beautiful thing the
general sentiment is that these dudes
aren't likely to win anything important
so only some free but exist the hunters
PLI services only usually also be there
so like some after Allah those who need
to be either like some muth visa for
[ __ ] or the fact this camera are
capable appeal a fight doesn't eat large
and honestly it's that what if that
makes this dig experiment so exciting
these dudes may be older than most and
considered past their prime
with the exception of newcomer hall zerk
but they still are csgo legends and for
a long time get right was even
considered the best player in the world
yet right for me is you have a player
that has been the best player in the
world for several years a guy like that
doesn't just drop off of the face of the
planet some might describe this big
experiment as a group of vets this last
chance to run it back before retirement
but if these guys can win and satisfy
the voice in our heads they have a
chance to redefine how the community
looks at aging pros now let's see a big
can make us believe once or thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages